as we talked about in other videos
shortly after the Declaration of
Independence in July of 1776 the
representatives from what were colonies
but now self-declared states had to
think about how to organize themselves
and so they start drafting the Articles
of Confederation which go into effect in
1781 now as we'll see these articles of
confederation do not provide for any
type of real central government it
really was a mutual defense union with a
little bit of free trade as we'll see in
the text here this is some of the
beginning passages of the Articles of
Confederation and I encourage you to
read the whole thing it's actually quite
interesting but you immediately see that
it has a very different tone than the
one that we see in the US Constitution
the Constitution starts with we the
people while the Articles of
Confederation starts with to all to whom
these presents shall come so it's almost
you know kind of an awkward business
letter we the undersigned delegates of
the states affixed to our names send
greeting Articles of Confederation and
perpetual union between the states of
New Hampshire Massachusetts Bay Rhode
Island and Providence Plantations
Connecticut New York New Jersey
Pennsylvania Delaware Maryland Virginia
North Carolina South Carolina and
Georgia the style of this Confederacy
shall be the United States of America
each this part is interesting each state
retains its sovereignty so it rules over
itself it's not giving up its
sovereignty to some type of a Union so
it retains its sovereignty its freedom
and independence and every power
jurisdiction and right which is not by
this Confederation expressly delegated
to the United States in Congress
assembled so they're really viewing
themselves as independent countries that
are next to each other that for the sake
of fighting the Revolutionary War agree
to things like mutual defense and free
trade but they are really separate
countries the said states hereby
severally enter into a firm league of
friendship with each other for their
common defense so this is that mutual
defense idea
the security of their liberties and
their mutual and general welfare binding
themselves to assist each other against
all force offered to or attacks made
upon them or any of them on account of
religion sovereignty trade or any other
pretense whatever and then it says the
better to secure and perpetuate mutual
friendship and intercourse among the
people of the different states in this
union the free inhabitants of each of
these states shall be entitled to all
privileges and immunities of free
citizens in the several states and the
people of each state shall free ingress
and regress to and from any other state
and shall enjoy therein all the
privileges of trade and commerce so
people can travel back and forth between
these states there would be free trade
but these would be viewed as different
countries one interesting thing that you
don't hear people talk a lot about
there's even a little passage here that
allows Canada to join this Confederation
Canada a ceding to this Confederation
and adjoining in the measures of the
United States shall be admitted into and
entitled to all the advantages of this
Union but no other colony shall be
admitted into the same unless such
admission be agreed to by nine states so
they're saying hey if Canada agrees
where they are pre agreeing to allow
Canada to join this Union which
candidate obviously does not join but
it's interesting to think that they they
thought about this now what are the
weaknesses here well the most obvious
one I don't have the entire Articles of
Confederation here but how does this
United States of America wield its power
where does its money come from it turns
out that if it needs to generate revenue
in order to take some action it can't
tax the citizens of the states the
states can only do that themselves
instead it has to apply to the States in
order to contribute to the United States
of America if you wanted to take some
type of unified action well you would
have to have delegates from the various
states and meet together and decide what
to do you wouldn't have any strong
leader being able to take decisive
action and so there really wasn't a
notion of a central government here
there wasn't even a notion of one
country it one nation it really was a
different sovereign states and all of
this as you'll see will come to a head
in the mid 1780s the United States has a
significant amount of debt exiting the
American Revolutionary War debt to
countries like France
you also have debt on an individual
level merchants owe money to European
merchants and traders and lenders and
these lenders weren't interested in
paper currency from these newly created
states they wanted hard currency they
wanted gold and they want silver and so
many of the merchants in the United
States in turn put pressure on the
people they lent money to especially
poor farmers many of whom had been
veterans in the Revolutionary War to pay
their debts in hard currency and so you
can imagine these poor farmers were kind
of the bottom of this food chain were in
a pretty tough bind they had fought in
the Revolutionary War they had risked
their lives many of them had been
injured but they actually did not get
paid for their service to a large degree
and then now they were not able to even
survive as farmers because not only were
they not able to borrow new funds but
some of their existing funds they had to
pay back and hard currency which wasn't
available in the United States and so
all of this tension eventually comes to
a head in western Massachusetts this
right here is a picture of Daniel Shays
who was one of these poor farmers in
western Massachusetts who was also a
veteran of the American Revolutionary
War who was not paid for his service and
so he eventually becomes one of the
leaders of these rebellious former
veterans poor farmers and they start
taking the courthouses of Western
Massachusetts making them inoperable
these are the courthouses where people
had to report to in order to talk about
how they would repay their debt well you
can imagine this worried many of the
merchants who these people owned their
debt to it also worried many of the
founding fathers because it took some
time for the government of Massachusetts
to be able to react to this and while
that was happening through
mid 1786 into the beginning of 1787 this
rebellion got stronger and stronger and
stronger
eventually On January 25th 1787 we see
things coming to a head where Daniel
Shays is leading his rebels to take the
armory in Springfield Massachusetts
which is in western Massachusetts but it
stopped by militia this is a militia
that's paid for by merchants in the area
who probably want their debts paid or
just wanted functioning courthouses or
did not want all of these rioting
farmers and former veterans and so this
rebellion is put down but it shows the
weakness
inherent in the Articles of
Confederation this rebellion starts
having the potential to spread well
beyond Massachusetts but there was not a
coordinated action in fact it took many
months to even be able to field a
militia against the rebellion it also
highlighted the weakness of not having
one central government that can take
decisive action also one central
government that could generate its own
revenue through taxing the citizens of
all of the states and using that for
things like a military or being able to
negotiate debts with foreign countries
and so Shay's rebellion is cited by many
historians as one of the main catalysts
after it was put down for having the
Constitutional Convention in mid 1787
to rethink the Articles of Confederation
now as we talked about in other videos
many people went to this convention
thinking we're not just going to edit
the Articles of Confederation
we need to create a stronger central
government we need a federalist system
where yes the states can have rights but
we also need a central government we
need a strong leader at the head of that
central government and so they do draft
that what is now the Constitution at
this convention then after the
convention they sell this new
constitution because remember it has to
be ratified by the states through the
Federalist Papers which we also talk
about in other videos
Hamilton organized it but James Madison
and John Jay also significant
contributors and eventually the Articles
of Confederation does get replaced the
Constitution is
defied and it becomes effective on March
4th 1789